hi I'm John I used to earn $70,000 a
year ago and today and make 110 thousand
dollars a year all thanks to my data
science certification let's talk about
the data science certification and why
you should consider a career in data
science you may wonder what is data
science all about data science isn't
just a buzz a trend or a fad it's a
revolution that's changing the world
with its tangible impact it's the study
of where information comes from what it
represents and how it can be turned into
a valuable resource when devising
business and IT strategies no wonder
every organization considers data
science as its biggest asset in today's
competitive environment it's one of the
few fields that finds application across
various industries including finance
retail healthcare manufacturing sports
and communication data science
professionals are sought after at some
of the biggest names in business with
the likes of Google Facebook and Amazon
willing to pay hefty salaries to skilled
certified data scientists this is
precisely why Glassdoor has ranked it
number one on the list of best jobs and
the demand for data scientist has never
been greater the US alone will need
190,000 data scientist by 2018 and the
average salary they earn is $120,000 a
year I've got there you can too all you
need to do is equip yourself with a data
science certification and we've got just
what you need here's what you get with
simply learn to data science
certification 48 hours of live
instructor-led online training sessions
25 hours of eLearning
40 hours of real-life industry project
experience hands-on experience in
predictive modeling with our SAS and
Excel and experience certificate in data
science so are you ready to get the
century sexiest job sign up now
you